サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
はい よろしくお願いします
今日は知り方というテーマで話します
入門と書いていますけど
ちょっと入門は壊れるかもしれません
こう あの国から帰ったばかりで
結構すごい疲れていてね
ですから すごい勢いでサイトを作りましたけど
うーん かなり難しくなってしまったんです
今日は特別に このお釈迦様の教えをね
世に広げることこそ善行為なんです
ブッダの教えっていうのは宗教ではありません
すべての生命に 科学的に
現実的に 具体的に 正しい生き方を教えることなんです
だから 信じるもの何もないし
皆様を自由にするんであって
束縛することは全くありませんし
人間の尊厳を守ってあげて
生命の尊厳を守ってあげて
生命に自由を獲得するように
自由になる道をね 教えることだから
宗教にならない 宗教っていうのは束縛って意味ですからね
自由を教えるところはすべての自由なんですよ
我々は宗教 文化 いろんなもので束縛されて
制限されて かなりがんじがらめになっちゃって生きているんですね
ですから これはもうチョイスする
命をチョイスするところまで説かれているんですね
だから 人間なら知るべきものは
このお釈迦様が説かれた真理なんですね
だから 誰かがブッダのこの幸福の道を説くならば
それは人類にとって 他の生命にとって
これ以上の良いことがありません
だから あらゆるお布施の中で
法施真理を教えることがとても優れているんだとお釈迦様は説かれているんです
しかし 真理を教えることというのは
かなり大変難しい仕事なんですね
なぜならば 我々の心が真理を知れない
知れないように組み立て建てられているんです
初めからもう嘘を信じる
現実を否定するような仕組みなんです
我々の脳みそも心も だから
これ語ることっていうのは
世の中で一番難しいことなんです
なぜかというと お釈迦様さえも悟り開いてから
説法なんかするもんじゃないんだと決めたんだから
どれほど難しいかっていうこともありますね
で 皆様方は頭悪い悪いという意味じゃないんです
我々の脳がロックされているんです
この妄想の世界が事実というふうに理解するようにロックされているんですね
だから皆様に能力があっても
すごく知識人であっても
この壁があるんですよ
ブッダの真理はわからないようにという
通らないんですね この壁から
これはお釈迦様は無明の壁と言うんですけどね
無知の壁ですね だって情報は入らなくなっているんですね
もし情報が入ったら わかったら直ちに理解できる
直ちに人格が変わる 人間性を乗り越えてしまう
究極の限りない幸福 安穏
安楽で生きられるようになってしまいます
これ 次元破れなくなっているんです
だから 仏教の真理と とにかく仏教ではなくて
真理をね 事実を語ることでいっても
世の中で難しいことなんですね
それでまあ専門家の人々は
まあ出家の方々は一応説法してはいるんだけど
それで在家の方々もなんか一番いいとこが出家ばっかりでね
我々には説法する 奉仕するチャンスがないのではないかと
まあ昔もそういう悩みがあったんです
仏教徒の間でお布施したいんですよ
だったら一番究極の最高の布施をしたいんです
それだったら説法しなくちゃ
しかし説法できない どうしようかと
説法する資格もない  そういうことで
じゃあ説法を応援しましょうという習慣が現れたんです
そこで仏教から見れば
説法をするために必要な在家の方々にできることをやってくれると
私たちは気楽に説法ができるんですね
なぜならば この説法っていうのは
完全無料で教えなくちゃいけないんです
我々の側が でないと教えの価値がなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで 日本みたいな社会ではね
もうもう呼吸する以外となんでも金かかっちゃうんですね
ですから まあそういう講演会
説法会を作ると すごくお金がかかってしまいますね
またそれでいろんな法律が絡んできて
あれこれとかね もう邪魔ばっかりなんですね
そういうことで言いたいのは
今日のこの会場の説法の費用をね
お布施してくださいました
柳潤一さん かなり金額ですよ
この全部 このホールのね
費用をお布施して 今日の説法会を実現できるようにとしていただきました
ですから 柳潤一さんにも
まあお母さんとかね また部下の親戚の方々やら
自分の親しい人々やら
皆様にも この偉大なる功徳の力で幸福が訪れますように
希望通りに生きられますように
智慧が現れますようにと
苦しみがなくなりますようにと
まず祝福誓願をいたします
はい それでテーマに入りましょう
まず 知るという機能の解説
あの知ることっていうのは一つの機能でしょう
ものを知る これがみんな誰も勉強していない
ただ知りたい 知りたい
調べましょう 調べましょうばっかしで
知るそのものがどんなからくりでしょうかと勉強したことがないんですね
で そこから仏教は この世間では誰も触らない
ものすごい難しいところを説明してくれたんですね
例えば科学世界では これはどうしても発見することはできないものなんです
研究方法が変わると 将来発見するかもしれませんだけど
ブッダが語られた真理はね
発見する方法すらまだないんです
そこで この知ることには
仏教専門用語でヴィンヤーナというんですね
これを識という言葉になりますが
単純機能ではありません
知るということは単純機能ではありません
そちらにヴェーダナ 感覚が必要です
要するに体で感じなくちゃいけないんですね
体で感じる場合は  5つの 6つの方法で感じるんです 6
種類のデータを感じるんですね
これは眼耳鼻舌身意といいますけど
目 耳 鼻 舌 体 それから心
という 6つのところで 6種類のデータ感じるんです
そこで想サンニャーというものがあるんです
サンニャーっていうのは
この想という専門用語は想なんですけど
概念ですね 私がこれ わかりやすく概念にするんですね
感じたものが概念でないと理解できません
だから 今まで自分が知っている知識
概念が必要です 次にサンカーラ
サンカーラっていうのは心のエネルギーなんですね
だから知りたいというエネルギーが生まれなくちゃいけないんですね
知りたがる衝動も必要なんです
それまとめたら ヴィンヤーナ
知るということが起こるんです
この 4つの機能が一体として働いて知るということになります
だから 何か知ったとは
純粋に知ったわけじゃなくて
あらゆるものそれの中に入っているんです
何かを知ったとすると
その知識の中に自分の評価
感情 自我 私がいるんだという自我
それから知ったものを所有する気持ち
それから弁解する気持ちなどなどのあらゆる執着も現れてくるんですね
一緒なんです 何か知ったら知ったそうというふうに自慢するんですよ
それで私が知りましたよって私も入ってくるんです
すべて専門用語で想サンニャーに入るんです
それから自分が知ったことに誰かが反論したら腹が立ちます
何言うのかと だから愛着も生まれているんです
純粋じゃないんですよ
だから知ることは常に主観で汚れているんです
ですから 知ることはヴェーダナ感覚
サンニャー想 概念 サンカーラ
行 衝動の働きです だから今言ったことは
感覚 想と行も混ぜて知るという知識になります
だからわかりやすい知識とは
常に感情で汚れている
これ教育世界で知識を
育てなくちゃいけないでしょ
だから ものを簡単にわかる
理解する 知ってもらうために
感情と一緒にあげればいたって簡単です
先生が歴史の授業をやっていると
一生懸命アニメーションでも書いてね
スクリーンで流しちゃうとすぐ覚えちゃうんです
例えばナポレオン・ボナパルトの話をしようとすると
もうスクリーンにどことんとことんとナポレオンのアニメーションが出てくると
で ちょっと俺がナポレオンだぞとかね
そうやって威張ってる顔でも姿でも作っちゃうと
子供たちがすぐそこを覚えちゃうんです
そこで何年生まれて何年死んだのかとも覚えているんです
なぜかというと 知識に感情を入れちゃったんですね
ケーキ作る時は上いろいろする入れるでしょ？ドレッシングみたいなね
いろんなものをデコレーション
ケーキはただの甘いパンばっかりなんですけど
デコレーションでうまくいっちゃいますよ
だからこの 教育の世界ではね
どんなからくりすれば覚えてくれるのかというと
どうしても感情に 訴えることなんですよ
だから面白い 楽しいということも感情の一つなんですね
で 科学研究などなどの場合は
この感覚を使うですね
医学とかはね 指で触って感じるというね
それも必要なんです 例えばがんがあるところは普通より臓器が硬いと
言っただけで実際使えないんです
だから普通の感想とがんがある感想が触ってみなきゃね
医者が その場合は感覚ですね
で 感覚でわかるものっていうのは結構ありますよ
そういうことで 知識とは
例えば目が見えない人はね
ほとんどもう感覚 体の感覚で勉強しますよ
だから結論は 知識はいつでも感情で汚れているんです
はい 次の問題はこの我々にとってはこの知らずにいられないという
なんか痒みがあるんですよ
ウズウズしているんですね
かい 痒くて 痒くてたまらん
知りたくて知りたくてたまらんですよ
これは人間だけじゃないんです
他の動物なんかを見ても
やっぱり知りたくてたまらん状態が見えるんですね
動物なんか知ることなくなっちゃうとすぐ寝るんです
で なんでこの痒みがあるんですかね
生きるとはヴェーダナ感覚
サンニャー想概念 サンカーラ行あるいは衝動
ヴィンヤーナ知ること
識が絶えず働くことです
これよく覚えてください
これ皆様 科学ものすごい学んでいるかもしれませんだけど
生物学も学んでいるかもしれませんだけど
命の定義できないでしょう
ないんです 科学世界では
で これは命の定義なんです
生きるとは この 4つ えーと
これは仏教用語にすると受想行識になっちゃいます
発音しやすくしていますよ
ヴェーダナー サンニャー
サンカーラ ヴィンヤーナ
感覚 概念 衝動 識 認識 そこ 4つがすーっと回転しているんです
だから 知る 知る 知る 知る
知るということは 生きる
生きる 生きる 生きるなんですね
だから命という何かないんです
これが命ですというものはないんです
知ってるか知らないか
いたって簡単 例えばこのペットボトルは命ですかと
生きているんですか？と言えば生きていない
ペットボトルは何も知らない
知らない 知ることは不可能です
だと思いましょう ペットボトルに聞かなきゃわかりませんだけどね
しかし この物体は知ることで成り立っています
例えば 私の感覚なければ立てないでしょう
体に感覚なければ喋れないでしょう
いろんなものを認識しなきゃ
言葉が出てこないでしょ
だからまぶたを閉じたりすることさえ
細胞が縮んだり膨らんだりしますね
伸び縮み この伸び縮みさえ
この知ることによって成り立っているんです
だから命というものはないんです
これが命ですよと 例えば
ある生命をとってね 生き物を取って
じゃあ命を取り上げますと
取り上げられません 我々ができることは
この認識機能をストップさせることなんです
何か取り上げて あ これが命ですということはできません
例えばどうする？何か注射をする
注射をしちゃうと 心臓がもう感覚がなくなっちゃって動かなくなる
そうすると血液が行かないんだから
他の臓器も感覚がなくなっちゃって死んでしまうということになる
いわゆる機能停止する
それから何も感じない状態になる
それが死んだというんで
命がなくなったと 命がなくなってないんです
機能が停止してしまっただけなんです
だから 仏教以外の世界では
何か命がある 命があるという風に妄想で思っているだけで
科学的に立証することはできません
仏教は生きるとは 受想行識という 4つがずっと回転しているんです
これは一つになっているんです
離れません 離すことはできません
でも一緒になると別々に味認識はできます
区別できます 味噌汁を飲んでいる
食べている時でもね 塩味を別に感じることはできるし
味噌の味を別に感じることはできるし
出汁の味を別に感じることできるし
味噌汁の具を別々に感じることもできます
全部まとめていっぺんに食べることもできます
しかし 味噌汁の中でこの味
綺麗に分かれることはできません
はい 味噌汁の出汁の味だけ取り出しましょうと
できませんね 味噌汁にジャガイモを入れてるんだと
じゃあジャガイモの味は別に取り出しましょうと
これは不可能ですね そういうことで
ウェーダナサンニャサンカーラっていうのは一つで働くんです
味噌汁と同じ意味で しかし
別々な機能であることは理解できます
これが生きることなんです
ということは何かわかりますか？知らずにいられないんです
だって知ることは生きることですよ
だから私は最初に知ることっていうのはいつでも汚れていると言ったでしょうに
そんな汚れていると言ったってもね
この汚れた知ることが回転するんです
常に変化して流れる縁起です
生きることっていうのは
だって目の前でね スクリーン見ると別な視覚
壁を見ると別な視覚 天井の方を見ると別な視角でしょ
変わるんですよ 皆様の目の感覚が変わらなきゃ
私は手を動かすと見えないでしょうに
私はこうやって手を動かすと見えますね
なぜ目がデータが矛盾だからなんです
流れるんだからなんです
だから生きるということがものではなくて
ストリームなんです ストリーム
一つのストリームといったら
まあもう川みたいなね
一つの流れ 知る機能が次の行為を行うために必要です
だから生きるためにいろんなことをしなくちゃいけない
立ったり座ったり 歩いたり
喋ったり 手を上げて下げたりとかね
見たり聞いたり あらゆることをしなくちゃいけないんです
生きるために 生きるという場合は
そこで判断しなくちゃいけないんです
手を上げるかないか ご飯食べるか
ラーメン食べるか 判断しないと
水を飲むか コーラを飲むか
喉が渇くっていうことは感覚
知ってます 喉が渇いてる
もう知ってます 次 喉の渇き状態と
また自分の他の感情を混ぜて
水飲むかコーラ飲むか
やっぱりコーラにします
甘いんだからとかね その人は感情で判断する
だから見たり聞いたり喋ったりしなきゃ
もう死んでる 生きてないでしょうに
だから生きるために判断しなきゃいけないんですよ
判断するために知ることが必要です
コーラって何者？どんなものかとわからない人は
コーラ飲もうと判断しませんね
ただ ちっちゃな子供たちが喉が渇いたら
喉が渇いた 水ちょうだい
あるいはジュースちょうだいと言うんであって
自動販売機でずっと子供たちを見ているのは可愛いんですよ
ジュース売ってるとこをずっと見て見て見て
自分に一番美味しいものを選んでるとこはね
しかし 子供たちは間違ってでもホテルとかはね
酒も自動販売機にあるんですよ
間違ってでもそちらには行かないんですね
だって誰も見てないんだったら
ビール 1本買っちゃえばいいでしょ
買わない なぜ？経験ないんです
知らないんです 知らないんだから
知らないものについて我々は判断しない
私たちもこの知らないことにはすごい不安を感じるでしょう
知らない人が来るとちょっと緊張しちゃう
で こちら私はもう見て見て見て飽きちゃってるんだから大丈夫やと思いますけど
まあ見たことがない外国の人が来たらちょっと緊張してしまっちゃうんです
あ こんにちはと言えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから行動するために知るってことが必要なんです
ですから 生きることには絶対的な
必要なものは知ることなんです
要するに 生きるために知ることが欠かせない
ということで 我々は知り
まくっちゃうんです 生まれた時から
赤ちゃんから何度かなんとか知って
知って 知って 知って 赤ちゃんもお母さん抱っこすると気持ちよくいる
知らない人が抱っこするとギャーッと泣く
判断しています なんで泣くのかと
この赤ちゃん知らない
ただ 匂いが違う 感覚が違う
知らない 知らないことを不安になって怯えになるんです
だからギャーッと泣くんです
私は実験していますよ
なんとなく言葉を喋れるような状態になったら
子供聞いたことあるんです
なんで君泣く？と ただ
まず怒っちゃいますよ
変な質問するんだからね
お母さん そんな質問絶対お父さんは聞かないしね
全く他人が変 チャラで質問するんだからね
それで子供はこれ答えなくちゃいけないんだから
考えて考えて言うのは
知らない なんで泣くのかと
ただ泣いちゃう それだけ
でも私は知ってるんですよ
だから 自分知らないデータに触れると泣いてしまうんです
私たちは大人だから泣かないんだけど
同じことなんですよ 知らない環境に行っちゃうと
すごく緊張しちゃって
硬くなっちゃって 喋れなくなっちゃって大変です
早く逃げようっていう感じになるんです
そこで存在欲ありますよ
生きていきたいっていう
このテーマは このスライドは
このテーマなんですね
存在欲っていうのは 仏教用語は渇愛なんですね
生きていきたい 生きていきたいという気持ちなの
死にたくない 死にたくないという
渇愛と書いているのは
これ終わらないんですね
生きていきたいという希望が叶って
全うした ゴールに達したってことはないんです
だって流れだから流してあげないと
そういうことで渇愛というんですね
存在欲 生きていきたい
死にたくない気持ちがある限り
知欲 まあ知欲 知欲って日本語の単語ないんだけどね
私はわざわざ単語を作るんです
知るというね 知識欲にですね
を生かして 自分のことを
世界のことを知り続けなくてはならないんです
だから知ることが欲にならないと
大変です そこで本当は存在欲なんですよ
生きていきたいという存在欲がある
誰も気づいてない その代わりに知ることに欲を抱くんです
知らなきゃ大変やと 知らなきゃやばいぞと
それで知欲になっちゃうんです
我々はものを知りたがっている
あの気持ちが存在欲なんです
自分の都合ですから 自分の都合で知るんです
ありのままの真理を知る目的はありません
私にとって地球が丸かろうと四角いものであろうか
どうでもいいんです 自分の存在を生き続けるために
存在を維持するために必要なものは必死で知るんです
だから自分の都合で知るんです
例を出しているかどうかはわかりません
それで問題が起こります
自分が知ることが自分にとって事実
自分にとって真理 だって生きられますから
他人にとっては同じではありません
ちょっと難しいでしょ？たとえでよくわかります
マグロって美味しいでしょ
これ 人間の知識なんですね
マグロは刺身で食べることは
日本人にとってはとても美味しい
外国人は生で食べませんからね
しかし 日本人がマグロって美味しいですよと
大トロというんですかね
食べたことないんでわかりませんだけどね
高いもの あれは最高やと言ってるでしょ
これ 皆様の知識でしょ？で
試しにインド人に言ってみて
インド人には結構合うでしょ
できるだけ長く日本に住んでる人じゃなくて
普通のインド人にマグロ結構美味しいですよ
刺身でと言ったら この人えらい気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですよ
ぎりっとなっちゃうんです
だから自分の知識は他人に知識じゃないんです
だから私は面白く書いただけで
マグロは美味しいと人間が思うんだけど
マグロの知識がどうですか？俺って美味しいですか？かと思ってるんですかね
俺はね サンマより美味しいですよと
だからマグロにとっては
人間の知識はとんでもない迷惑
とんでもない誤解なんですよ
勘違いですよ 人間が自分の知識正しいと思っちゃうと
マグロが死ななくちゃいけない
すごい人間凶暴だから
自然界のマグロは今かなり減ってるんです
もうなかなかすごい簡単に取れなくなってるんです
例えば我々は自分の知識
例えば化石燃料をバンバン使う
人間だけです 人間にとってそれは素晴らしい知識です
人間があのなんとか革命を起こしたでしょ
何て言いますか あれは
産業革命  産業革命起こしちゃって
機械作っちゃって 車作っちゃって楽ちんで
でも全ての生命に 植物にさえものすごい迷惑なんですね
だから人間の知識が地球の他の生命としてはものすごい恐ろしいことになっているんです
そういうことで勉強しましょう
我は知るということがかなり大変ですよ
私が知ってることで どれぐらい他の生命に迷惑かとわからなくなっちゃうんです
もう一度初めから考え直しましょう
知ることは欠かせません
知ることがなくなったら生きていられない
命もなくなるんです だから我々はどうしても知るということをしなくちゃいけない
生きるために 知りまくっちゃまくらなくちゃいけない
呼吸と同じですよ ハメられている
どうしても呼吸しなくちゃいけない
同じく知らなくちゃいけないんです
皆様は呼吸なんかは簡単にわかりますけど
本当は知ることも同じなんですよ
瞬間でもそれストップできません
知る知る 知る知るということで続けるんです
そこで知ることで大変疲れるんだから
心が寝るという よくわけもわからない何かの状況まで作っているんです
だって本読んだり喋ったりすると知識で疲れるんだから
それで寝るという知る流れが行くんですね
寝ることも知ることの流れなんです
はい そういうわけで どんな生命も知ることがすごくありがたいと思っています
我々は皆 一般の方々は
このラーメンよりは蕎麦美味しいとかね
そんな程度の知識はあまり大したことないと思っているんですね
味噌作るならば出汁入れてくださいというのは大した知識じゃない
しかし 学校で学んだこと
大学で学んだこと 大学院生として学んだこと
科学を研究してきた 発見したこと
歴史学者であること 考古学者であること
えらい自慢しているんです
くだらんんだけどね 汚れてる知識ですよ
考古学者は考古学的な知識に対してすごく愛着を持って自慢して自我を張るんです
弁護士やら法律関係の人々は
法律の知識をものすごく愛着して自慢して
それは自分の自我として身分として出すんです
私は弁護士ですと あれは知識自慢なんですね
ということは 我々は知識をとってもありがたがっています
ありがたがらないと大変ですよ
だってね 生きられなくなっちゃうんです
しかし それは知智ではなく愚痴なんです
これはイコール主観なんです
存在欲の刺激で知るので
その知が自分に限った主観になります
例えば 皆様方はお茶がおいしいと思う
私が紅茶がおいしいと思っている
これ知ることなんです
お茶はおいしいと知っている
私が紅茶がおいしいと知っている
これは私の主観なんです
お茶おいしいと思うのは皆様の主観なんです
だからどちらが本当においしいかと決定することは不可能でしょう
本当においしいのは日本のお茶ですか？紅茶ですか？と
緑茶ですか？ブラックティーですか？と
どうやって判断する？飲んでみなきゃあかんでしょ
味比べしなきゃあかんでしょ
そうすると その人は判定するでしょ
その人の主観なんです
あんまり意味がないんです
普遍性 客観性がないので
知が真理事実ではありません
これで仏教の世界を理解しましょう
仏教から見れば 知識は真理ではありません
事実ではありません しかし
それは極端的に否定するんじゃなきんです
世間では知識だと言いますよと
例えば ある日本の方が
玄米しか食べないんだと
白米はまずいと思っているとしましょう
あまりそういう人はいないかもしれませんだけどね
あるいは玄米は嫌い 白米が好き
おいしいと決めたり それは全く嘘ではなくて
その人にとっては事実っていうところはわかっています
ある人はエビ食べる場合は天ぷらでしか食べない
あるいはエビを揚げたものでしか食べないとか
自分勝手な主観を作れます
本人にとってはその通りで
天ぷらにしたエビがおいしいと思う人にとっては
当然そのエビがおいしいんです
で 寿司として あるいは刺身として出てくるエビはおいしくない
天ぷらにしてないんだからね
それは仏教は認めます
あれは世間の考え しかし真理ではありません
主観に対する仏教用語は偏見ですね
この偏というのは この漢字通りの意味なんです
パーシャル ある偏ってある枠で見ているという
すべての生命は人間だけではなく
神々も人間も動物も地獄の生命も
よくわかりませんだけど
お化けもみんな幽霊も偏見で生きているんです
知が正解ではないので
生命にさらに知らなくてはならない渇愛が生じる
だから自分が何か知ったからといって
それは偏見でしょ そうすると
もっと知らなくちゃいけないという渇愛が生まれるんです
だから生き物が知る 知る
知る知る 限りなく知って知って知っていくんです
終わりがないんです なぜならいくら知ってあんの？それが偏見なんです
それでその形を変えてまた知る
それも偏見になる だから子供はね
最初にパステルでクレヨンで絵を描く
どんどんそこを成長して
あの なんとか水で溶ける絵の具ありますね
そういうものでも描くようになる
それからもうちょっと成長して
あの なんとか絵の具がありますね
あの なんて言いますか
油絵 油絵 それで描いたりする
紙に描いていた子がもうさらに成長してキャンバスに描くようになる
しかし 自分の知識が変わったんだけど
すべて偏見です なぜならば
キャンバスで描くこともあるし
壁にフレスコとして描くこともできます
例えばキャンバスで立派な絵を描く人にとっては
フレスコを描いてくださいと言ったら描けませんよ
壁に描かなくちゃいけないんだから
まあ描く人は描くかもしれませんけど
フレスコとしてはもうもう 100年でも 200年でも持つように描かなくちゃいけないんです
だから絵の具の調整が違うんです
壁の作り方も変わるんです
本当は壁を作って乾く前に描くんです
ちょうどいいところに来たら描いて
絵の具と壁の作ったものが一緒になるようにするんです
相当技術が違うんです
はい それでも偏見は偏見です
だからさらに知らなくちゃいけない
さらに腕を上げなくちゃいけないということになる
死ぬまで 理由は あんた今知っていることは不完全ということなんです
それで生き続けることも
輪廻転生も成り立ちます
だからいくら知ったっても物足らないんだから
さらに知ることにするんですよ
衝動が生まれるんです
さらに知ろうと 知りましょうと
それで命が死んでも終わらないということになっているんです
これは一般人が否定する
人が死んだら生まれ変わるということはもうおかしいと
あれは初めから誤解しているんです
命があると勘違いしているんです
だからその誤解が起こる
命がないんです エネルギーの流れなんですよ
エネルギーの流れはストップしないでしょ
ストップしない 至って単純です
エネルギーはここで終わりということはあり得ない
で 放射線ってどういうものかというと
だから放射のあの レディエーション
素粒子たちが行って 何かの物質に入っちゃう
入っちゃうとそちらにある素粒子が追い出す
追い出された粒子は自由にいられませんだからどこかに引っかかっちゃう
引っかかっちゃう そちらのものは出ていく
そういうわけで もう 10万年
20万年でも放射汚染があるんですよ
ジャガイモを被曝したら
ジャガイモと一緒にいた他のものを被曝する
でもあの元から出た同じ放射ではないんです
もう変わってるんです
そういうことで これあの機能の変化だから
エネルギーの流れだから
仏教から見れば え？輪廻転生ってあんた信じないの？初めて聞いた話だと
だから仏教から見れば
輪廻転生ないっていうことほど
こんなアホな人と だから亀みたいな感じで
甲羅からは逃げられない人間なんですね
何もできない はい ここで ２行目にあるこの普遍性という言葉を覚えてください
これはスライド書いてないと思いますけど
あったらあったでいいんですけど
我々の知識に時々普遍性が見えるんです
普遍性っていうのは 自分が知っていることを他の人も見ている
科学的例えではなく 仏教の例えで考えてください
花はきれい こちらにある花は一応きれい
美しいでしょうね これは事実ではないんですけどね
しかし 人間同士で同じ知識を作るんです
だから我々人間だけ 花がきれいとは事実であると信じているんです
人間の主食は何なのかというと
まあご飯か小麦粉で作ったものでしょうと
アジアはご飯主食で 西洋の方はまあ小麦粉で作った
それで似ているものもありますね
アフリカとか別にね トウモロコシやら
あるいはキャッサバとかね
いろんなでんぷんものを食べたりする
いわゆる同じものですね
そこで我々はそれは正しいものであると思っているんですね
人間の主食はほうれん草ですよと言っちゃうと
どうなる？人間の主食とはほうれん草ですと言っちゃうと
私はちょっとおかしいでしょう
みんなそう思うんです
おかしい と言うんです
なんで？普遍性がないんです
そこで誰だって数学は正しいと思ってるでしょ？科学で発見するものは正しいと思ってるでしょ
なぜ？普遍性なんです
鉄を温めると簡単に曲げると
曲げられると あるいは伸びると
いうのは 誰がやってみたって同じ結果になる
この普遍性がの値がね
高い方が結構平和なんです
そこから入っていると思います
主観的知と客観的知 当然客観的知が承知になります
この承知という言葉も
私はいい加減使っている単語で
普通の日本語の辞書にはないものです
しかし 知識は存在欲を支える目的で起こるんです
知識は存在欲です 承知になるのは稀です
稀です ならないと決定はできません
稀です 人間の知識 科学
技術 芸術などには普遍性
共通性があります 世界では知識というのは共通性
普遍性が高い値を取るものです
だから論文を書いて世界的な知識になるのは
普遍性の値が高いんです
それだけです 世界的に認められる学者というならば
その人が言うことは 例えば経済学にも時々
あの なんとかメダル取るでしょ
ノーベル賞 そこで私は経済学でノーベル賞を取ったと話を聞いて
その人の経済学の本を読んでみたんです
私は経済学を知らないよ
そうすると 私とちんぷんかんぷんになるはずなんですけど
何のことはない 見事に理解できる
気に入る ああ なるほど
その通り その通りだと
ということは この超エリートの経済学者が書いている彼の経済学は
普遍性の値があまりにも高い
まるっきり素人にすらわかります
そういうわけで 我々はこの知識世界
科学世界 発明の世界と言っているのは
IT 世界 普遍性の問題ですよ
例えば IT ってどうったことないんだけど
今携帯持ってない人間いませんだからね
普遍性が 広がっちゃったんです
そこで仏教的なポイントは
でも知識でしょ 汚れている
事実ではありません 正解ではありません
はい それからまあ 基本的な勉強はそれで終了しましょう
それからまあ それに関連する
今日は私は時計あります
うーん まあ休憩になった方がいい時間になったんだけどね
問題点考えましょう  1 主観であり
偏見であること  2 存在欲をかき回す
刺激する目的ですね 知識は
知識が増えても存在欲が確定するだけで無明はなくなりません
知識であってもあっても
無明はそのまま いわゆる真理
知らないのは変わらないんです
物知り屋ですけど だから結構世の中で物知り屋はいっぱいいるんだけど
真理は知る人はいません
無明がある限り 生命の知欲は絶えない
この無明があるから 我々に存在欲があるんです
勘違いしているんです
私がいるのだと 私に尊い魂が
尊い命があるのだというトンデモない勘違い
それ研究しなくちゃいけないんですよ
研究してないんです だからそれを置いておいて
知識欲で頑張っているんです
もしも知が愚痴ではなく
正知になったならば さらに知る必要がなくなります
これで知欲消えます 知っていることは正知
正しいもの そうすると普遍性の値は100です
誰にも違うと言えません
お釈迦様は真理を語っている時は
世の中でどんな人間もしないトンデモない自慢をしたんです
すごい怖い自慢なんです
どういう自慢かというと
これ自慢とは言わない
我々は獅子空とライオンローと言うんですね
私が言うこの真理は真理でないと言える
出家もバラモンも知識人も
神々も梵天も悪魔も誰もいませんよと
誰にでもブッダが教えたことは間違っているよと言うことは不可能ですと
だからいまだにそのチャレンジはあるんです
ブッダがおかしいと言えるならば
言ってみてください なんであんなに将来にまで渡って渡って挑戦するんですか？お釈迦様が
承知だからなんです 知ったことは
偏見ではないんです だから本当はブッダの教えは間違っていると頑張っている方々
結構いますよ 結局自分が馬鹿になっておるだけなんです
また問題点なんですね
知るから起こる人間の欲望
何かを知ると 知らないものはありすぎると発見する
でしょ 文学を学ぶ人は
理科系も結構すごいものがあるものと知るだけなんで
理科系だけで勉強する学生が
文科系も膨大な知識があるなとかね
我々いつでも知っているものよりは知らないものがあまりにもありすぎやと気づくんですよ
それ気持ち悪いんですよ
知らずにいることは存在欲を脅しますよ
知るものよりは知らないものが多い
それだけで自分の存在欲が脅されてしまいます
存在欲が知識欲に変わりますが
知らないもの 知りたいものが増えるのであって
減りません 我々なんかかわいそう
一生懸命頑張って 知って知って知って
さらに知って さらに勉強していくんだけど
勉強すればするほど知らないものの量が大きくなるだけ
別に大きくなるわけじゃなくて
知らないものが多いと自分が気づくんです
知るものは少なくて 知らないものが多いとわかっちゃうと
存在欲が怯えるんです
なぜならば 存在するために知る機能が必要です
落ち着きがなくなります
知ると恐怖感と不安が生じます
私は昔知ってますよ この仲間でね
みんな研究して自分のレポートを発表するんですよ
ものすごい緊張したって
怯えちゃって もうもうなんか喋れない状態で
何やこれやと思うぐらい
だって自分が調べて調べて研究してレポート書いたんだけど
書いてる途中でこの分野で膨大なものがあるとわかってるんです
でも私は知らない こんなちっぽけなものを出しちゃうと
何言われるかわからないと
自分の存在が脅かされます
脅されているんです すごい苦しいんですよ
皆様ね もしかすると経験があると思います
研究発表なんかはものすごい地獄のような状態なんです
解決して解決通して妄想と神秘に依存します
そこで人間が存在欲を脅かしてはならんでしょ
存在欲を確定しなくちゃいけない
それで人間がなんか なんて言いますか
ずる賢いというか もうなんか嫌
なんか良くない 裏の手を使ったんです
妄想に依存したんです
神秘に依存したんです
神秘って単語正しいかどうか分かりません
ミスティック ミスティシズム
ミスティシズムの場合は証拠はない
例えばこのご飯がおいしいですよというと
ミスティック神秘じゃないんです
調べられますから 例えば地球の裏側に生命がいるんだよと
地球はいつでも月が半分しか見えませんだからね
ずっと地球に向かっている面は同じ
で 月の裏側に生命がいると思ったら
皆様笑っちゃうでしょ
神秘じゃない それは なぜならば
何か宇宙船を送ってね
調べられますからね 例えば火星には膨大な
なんていう優れた文化がありますよと言ってもいいんです
なぜならば あるかないか調べられますよ
そういうのは神秘じゃない
とんでもない嘘ですけど
神秘じゃないんです それでわかりますか？神秘っていうのは
どうすればいいかわからないんです
例えば 私の魂が神様が与えてくれたという言葉は神秘です
なぜ？どうやって調べる？方法ない
だから私の魂は神様が与えたっていう人がとんでもない神秘で
地球の間違った月の裏に生命がいるんだよという人は賢いんです
なぜ嘘を言ってるんだとはっきり言えますからね
そこで私たちはこの妄想に依存するんです
妄想すると 存在欲がいくらか
不安にならないで 保つことはできます
そこでこの推定を推定する宣誓者がいるんです
これ推定ですよ 人間が推定という単語がおかしいんですけどね
イマジネーションする
イメージ 妄想する 先知洗脳者がいると妄想します
推定します 先知洗脳者に従うこと
信じること 身を任すことを推薦して
神秘世界 信仰世界 作ります
あれ 何のため？存在欲を維持するためなんです
だって知らないものが多いんだから怖いんですよ
死ぬかもしれませんと思っちゃうんです
死にたくないでしょ これは科学的に具体的に獲得することはできない
だから妄想でやりましょうと
それで 全知全能者が妄想してすべて知っているとは
存在は確実です 全知全能者は永遠不滅です
死にません はっきりした存在です
我は絶対死なないという確信があるんです
全知全能者に すべて知ってるんだから
でもそんなものはいないんだから
人間がそこを妄想するんです
なぜそんなくだらない妄想をしたのかというと
知る世界で知らない方が多いとわかるからなんです
病気になったらなんで病気になったのかとわからないんです
突然白血病になっちゃうと
なんでしょうかね とわからないんです
知らない方が多いんです
そこで神様 何でもできる神様に頼むんです
何でもできる神様に 神様
うちの子の白血病を治してくださいと
グループ作って祈る 祈ってもその子は死にますね
でもあの神様を信じることだけはやめられません
だから非科学的なんですね
神様がいると私は信じている
神様は全知全能であると私は知っている
我々のことを何でも神様が知っている
しかし 私の子供がまだ子供なのに
白血病が突然現れて死にかけている
これはいけないことで
人間は寿命を全うして死んだ方が
まあどちらかというといいんです
だから神様 この過ちを直してくださいと言っても直してくれなかったら
神様がいないか 人の祈りは無視するかどちらでしょう
そうはない それでも神様を信じる
これは人間の存在欲から出てくる無知無明の問題なんです
それで存在欲から起こる不満
不安 怯えがなくなったと自己満足に陥ります
だから神様を信仰する人は結構自己満足ですよ
でも 神様は信じようが
神を否定して無神存在になろうか
人間は人間ですよ 何の差もないんです
神様を信じる人も夫婦喧嘩するし
無神論者も夫婦喧嘩する
神様を信じる人も 会社でいろいろトラブルがあるし
無神論者にも同じく会社に行ったらトラブルがある
全然同じです 何も特権ないんです
ただ 神様を信じる人がこの空自慢
から満足でいるんです
それでも不安 怯えというものだけが人を脅します
たとえ妄想に頼っても
神秘に頼っても 不満 怯えが消えません
消えることはできません
消すことも だって知ることが偏見だからなんです
自分の妄想が戦地者の御告げであると自分を騙し
他を騙す それからとんでもない詐欺師たちが
全知全能者が私にお告げをしましたと
天使が ガブリエル 車で思い出したんだけど
忘れた あのバカの名前がゲイブリエル
ガーベリエルでした 日本の発音はわかりませんけど
英語ではゲイブリエルと発音しますけど
このゲイブリエルと天使がイエススという人にもいろいろお告げをするんですね
で ムハンマドにもお告げするんですね
あのゲイブリエル野郎が
頭おかしいでしょ だって聖書の教えとコーランの教えが全く違うんですよ
頭イカれてます ゲイブリエルは
ゲイブリエルは天使なんですね
それで人を騙してるんです
神がお告げするならば
全知全能者が ちょっとでも神に理性があるならば
ほんのちょっと 針の先っぽぐらいの
でも理性があるならば
全ての人間にお告げするはずなんです
じゃあざまあみろと否定してみようと
普遍性ゼロでしょ ある頭がイカれてる人にお告げをするんです
だから見たら これっておかしいとわかるでしょうに
で 我々は存在欲があるんだから
ああ そうですか 神にお告げあったんですか？どうぞどうぞ教えてくださいと
信者さんになるんです
血が作るこの世界 そこで血がなければ生きられませんだけど
血が苦しみの世界を作るんです
だからお釈迦様は生きることは苦であると説かれていますね
自分の知識を守らなくてはいけない
血は他人の血と一致しない
互いに議論したり 争ったり
他を破壊したり 排他的に閉鎖的になったりもします
知識のせいですよ 例えばイスラム教なんかどれほど閉鎖的か
どれほど排他的かというと怖いでしょ
だから彼らのこと 我々は怖いだけじゃなくて
イスラム人の中ででも不安で怯えて生活しなきゃいけない
平和がないんです どこでもいつ殺されるか分からない
たとえサウジアラビアにしても
人間は自由で平和でいないんです
宗教はあまり表で働かない
日本人は平和でいる 自由はお互い様だと知っている
だからね 神様やと思ってないんですよ
だからどちらかで世界で日本人の生き方がものすごくいいんです
比較するとかなりトップになるんです
ランク付けると 理由は
まあ宗教はいくつか信仰してますけど
一つも自分決まってない
曖昧 その代わりにお互い人間関係を大事にする
お互いに仲良くすることは大事にする
人に迷惑をかけてはいけませんと
よく気をつけている だから平和で豊かにいられる
まあ完全にならないんだから
人間不完全だからね 日本でも泥棒が入りますよ
まあだからそれはそれで当然頭イカれた人がね
無差別殺人も起こるかもしれませんだけど
でもアメリカほどはないんですね
地から私は正しいという恐ろしい錯覚に陥ります
これは避けられない 私がすることは私にとって正しいんです
どうしようもないんです
だから恐ろしい 我は正しいという問題が起こる
人は人と分かれて個で生活する羽目になります
これで個が生まれるんです
本当は個はいません 生命もないんです
命もないんです すべてエネルギーの流れだけです
はい だから自分が他にたと違った子であると生きられませんよ
結構苦しみが生まれるんです
慈悲の代わりに愛着と憎しみが現れます
だから この神を信じる宗教でも愛を謳ってますけど
本物じゃないんです あれは愛着の変形バージョンだけです
お釈迦様が子がいないという前提で慈しみを教えたんです
そうすると 生命の流れが
命の流れがうまく流れるんです
邪魔がなく それは慈しみを実践しなさいと言って
ブッダだけが言ったんです
メッターという 他の宗教はプレマか愛ですね
それは人間感情の変形バージョンなんです
だから愛着があると憎しみもあります
それは子がいるからなんですよ
子がいると錯覚しているからなんです
はい これでちょっと 10分休憩しましょう
はい では 後半にやりましょう
で 知識については必要なものは説明して終わりました
知識に問題があるということも言いました
で そこで知識は今 ゴチという単語に入れ替えちゃうんですね
入れ替えてゴチを承知に変える方法
データが正しいという前に
データを判断する組織機械の問題を直すと
これは省略した結論なんですね
だから 知る場合は 我々は自分が自分だけ生きる目的で知ってるんですね
それから感覚 概念 衝動も混ざってるんですね
だからこの知る機械にちょっと問題があるんですね
純粋に知ることはできなくなっているんです
だから機械の誤作動 データを取る機械が正常に働かないならば
誤作動ばかりするならば
データを信頼できませんし
間違っているんですね
科学的な機械で考えてください
例えば重さを測るものでも
機械に問題があるんだったらちゃんと測れませんね
体重計であってもね 体重計に問題があるんだったら
自分の体重を正しく測ることはできません
それを無視して 例えば 5 キロの誤差がある体重計に乗って
私の体重はこれぐらいだと決めても
あのデータが間違ってます
存在欲が作った認識機能なので
真理を知るためではなく
生き続ける目的で知識データを合成したり
捏造したりする だから我々にはマグロが私たちと同じく苦しんで生きている生命だということは見えないんですよ
そういう風に見えない
あ 美味しいマグロだとかね
海で見つけたっても あ
すごい でっかいマグロ取ったら美味しいでしょうね
船の上で取ったばっかしの刺身食べるぞという知識になる
あ 生命だ 元気でいるんだという気持ちにならない
なぜならば 我々はデータを捏造する
自分のために 生きるために
私は知っているのだという錯覚は危険です
それで自分が生きるために作った知識で
私が正しいという錯覚が起こるんだから
これとんでもない危険なんです
だから機械の修理し 修理しなくちゃいけないんです
認識システムに依存する前に
認識システムはどのように作動しているのかと調べるんです
それから仏教なんです
世界ではそういうことは誰も言いません
認識はどのように起こるものかと
知恵は知ることがどのように起こるのかとちょっと調べましょう
仏教が説く自己観察 あるいは気づきの実践です
皆様に結構瞑想する方々に教えているんです
何か超越した知識を得るためではなくて
ただ観察してみてくださいと
そのまま 感情と存在欲が割り込んで
色声香味触法の情報を意識で捏造し
知識になる過程を発見できます
そこで このヴィパッサナー実習をやっていると
耳に入る情報が入って
自分でこれを処理して捏造して知識にする
これ見えてくるんですよ
目で何か見たら見えた
それから あ これってバラのお花だ
結構綺麗な花だとか捏造する
自分の存在のために あ
こういう風にこの機械が働いているんだと
認識機械がね で見えてくるんです
ものを知る前に自分が好き嫌いの判断していることを発見します
そこで我々は瞑想するともう一つ発見します
我々は知る前にもう判断しているんです
例えば弁当をもらったら
あ おいしそうと先に判断しているんです
まだ食べてないのに 犬なんか見たら
ああ 犬は可愛いに決まってるとか
可愛い可愛いと触ろうとしたら噛まれる可能性もあります
先入観で情報を判断している
いるって向けてますことが見えます
貪瞋痴の衝動で知ることを行って
知ることによって貪瞋痴が現れることも発見します
ただ この膨らみ縮みやら歩くことやら見えている
聞こえているとか それそれなりに確認していると
そういうのは自動的に見えてくるんです
なんでウロウロ周り見るのかと
瞑想中 やっぱり貪瞋痴なんですね
見たら結果は新たな貪瞋痴が生まれる
だから私は最近食べる瞑想も推薦していますけど
普通は貪瞋痴で食べている
そこで取る 運ぶ 入れる
噛む 噛む 味わう 飲む 込むというふうに確認すると
これシステム見えてくるんです
貪瞋痴で食べたくなったこと
食べてから貪瞋痴を作りたがっていたこと見えるんです
ここで感情の循環が起こるだけで
正しくすることは起きてないと発見します
何を発見するかというと
貪瞋痴で知る 知って貪瞋痴を作る
その貪瞋痴でさらに知る
知って さらに貪瞋痴を知る
増やす 増やす そういう循環だと
こいつは一度たりとも正しく知ることを知ってない
やってないんだと自分で発見します
いわゆる循環ですね 感情の循環が起きているだけだと
科学者であろうか 研究者であろうか
みんな感情の循環をやっているんだと
故障を発見したらそれを直さなくてはならない
もう故障を発見しました
認識しない 自分のね 先入観とで認識して
捏造するデータを じゃあ捏造することをやめなくちゃいかんでしょ
先入観にストップしなくちゃかんでしょ
このやり方があるんです
それから修理を施す 眼耳鼻舌身意に触れる色声香味触法の情報に愛着を抱くことも
対立することもやめて
そのまま放っておくことを訓練します
花を見たら あーきれいや好きという愛着を抱かない
ゴミ袋を見て ああ 気持ち悪いとかね
対立的いらだちは作らない
見えている それで修理なんです
もう修理施しているんです
先入観で見ない 貪瞋痴で見ない
貪瞋痴で見ないためには放っておくということが必要です
関わりを持たないこと
関わりは 2種類 執着するか
拒絶するかと これはお釈迦様の言葉で
アサンヒーランアサンクッパンという二言葉で教えているんです
皆様はその偈を知っていると思います
経典を知っている方はテキストにあります
アサンヒーランというのは
情報を抱くこともしないで
情報に逆らうこともしないという
私が使う単語は放っておく
ただ確認だけする 関わりは持たない
それ訓練です やったことない
だから訓練しなくちゃいけないんです
できるようになったら放っておくこと
貪瞋痴をかき回す目的がなくなって
もう貪瞋痴は生まれなくなっているんです
ヴィパッサナー実践やると貪瞋痴が生まれないんで
循環が壊れているんです
あるがままに現象を認識できるように成長します
そこで真理を発見します
愚痴ではなくて 承知が生まれてきます
花 人 家 国などの無数の知識は
捏造した現象であることを発見します
今まで頭の中にあるあの概念が膨大にありますよ
例えば単語はある限り概念があるんです
単語は数少ないんだけど
フレーズは無数にあるんです
例えば国って単語 1個でしょ
私の国 隣の国 と言ったら 2つですね
友好 味方の国 敵国 また変わるんです
そんなものはいくらでも作れますね
全て捏造なんです 限りなく概念捏造しているんです
それは見えてくるんです
国っていうのは捏造しなきゃ成り立たないんです
目に色が触れると その情報が花
人などの捏造に変わる過程が見えます
目にただ光のデータが入るだけ
入ったら私はあ 人です
男です 女です 若い人 年寄りとか捏造するんです
これは花です これはご飯です
これは野菜です とか 野菜は見えたわけじゃないんですよ
ただ同じ光のデータが入っただけ
野菜を見ても ワンちゃん見ても
同じデータが入るだけなので
同じ光のデータ そこで頭の中で捏造しているんだということは
ヴィパッサナーする人には何のことなく見えてくるんです
情報が瞬間的に変化する無常の流れで
それが見えてきます 情報が変化
無常で流れるんだったら
認識も無常で流れるんです
だから知ることで おかしいっていうのは知ったら止まるんですね
これはありえないんです
例えばある人と喋って
その人はすごく優しい人だと知るんです
それで私は優しい人だと知ったことを変化しないで持っているんです
変化させないで だってあれ愚痴でしょうし
捏造でしょうし それからもう後で
1週間後で その人と会って喋っちゃうと
その人は興奮しちゃって
ちょっといろいろいらだちがあって
もうちょっと失礼な態度をとるとびっくりしますよ
理解できなくなっちゃって
優しい人でしたのに それでその人と喧嘩する
なんであんたこんなことするのかと
だから恋する時はベタベタ恋しちゃって
結婚したら喧嘩するでしょうに
で 恋してる状況で あ この子は可愛いとかね
一生その人と一緒になりますとか
知識にするんですね でも実際は知識は瞬間瞬間変わるんです
これ このバカが知らないんです
だから結婚してからも
毎瞬毎瞬人は変わるんだと
データが変わるんだと知ったら問題ないでしょうに
だからそれが見えてくるんです
それから私がいる 他がいるということは成り立たないと発見します
私がいると思ったっても
このホールの中にいる私と
外を出たらの私が違うでしょ
そこで道路を歩く私がまた違うでしょ
駅に入る私がまた違うでしょ
電車に乗る私がまた違うでしょ
だって情報が変わるんだから
情報が変わると知識が変わるんだから
知識に私と錯覚しているだけ
知識イコール私であるならば
いつでも私は変化するんです
これ真理を発見していきます
知ることがあっても私がいません
それは真理です 私はいないなら他もいません
私がいないなら 存在欲は
いわゆる貪瞋痴は成り立ちません
今までの知識世界は錯覚であり
捏造であると発見することを智慧と言います
これが智慧というんです
いわゆる膨大な知識から解放されます
智慧がある人に知る必要が消えます
これで知る必要も消えます
それで一切智者という問題
考えましょう 宗教的な一切智者ではないんです
人は捏造するすべての妄想概念を知ることが一切智者ではありません
宗教はそう思っているんです
過去現在 未来 何でも知ってるバカがいるんだと
全知全能の神という妄想しているんです
考えてください そんなのはありえないんです
私は休憩中 ちょっと一つ例え話考えたんですよ
日本の総理は何者かと知ることにしましょう
どうやって知る？彼が喋ることを調べて
彼がやっていることを調べて
ニュースを見て それで大丈夫？日本の総理が政府等とやっていることは
その人全てじゃないでしょ
やりたいことはあっても
いろんな議論しなくちゃあかんだから
いろんな意見を取り入れなくちゃあかんだからね
だからそれって本物じゃないんです
それで本当に総理大臣何者か知りたければ
すべての国民に総理大臣に対して自分の主観を聞かなくちゃいけないんです
あんたどう思いますかと
これ不可能でしょ まず
すべての国民にアンケートを取らなくちゃいけない
一人も残らず その揃ったデータっていうのは結論に達することできる？できないんです
すべて主観だけだから
総理大臣大好きという人もいるかもしれません
総理大臣大嫌いという人もいるかもしれません
どうやってこれを合わせるんですかね
合わせないんですよ だから
すべてのネズソデータ知ろうとすると
これってあまりにもおかしくて
非現実的にありえない話なんです
だって私一人にも 今日は日本の総理大臣って立派な人やと思うことは可能です
そこで夜ニュース聞いたら
なんだこいつはと思うことも可能でしょ
そこで一人の私すら総理大臣に対して自分の知識は変えたんだから
そこで夜 なんだこいつは？と思った私が
まあ次の昼ニュースを見て
まあそうでもないみたいとかね
別な意見になる だからネズソした知識
そんなもんなんですよ
だからバカな人々は 愚かな人々は
これで全知全能の神を作って
過去現在未来何でも知ってるアホがいるんだと
だからこのアホがそう思うんですね
アホが思った概念もアホな概念でしょうに
それじゃないんです 生命には個人の知る世界があって
それも常に変化して別な知る世界になります
生命というのは いつでも個人が知る世界があるんです
二人で知ることは不可能です
だから唯一あるのは個人が知る世界
それも変化しているんです
認識システムを知り尽くすこと
誤作動を直すことで 一切の現象は無常・苦・無我であることを発見します
そこでこのブッダの方法を使って認識システムを知り尽くす
それで感情の循環をやめて誤作動を直す
直したら現象は眼耳鼻舌身意のある色声明臭法の現象が瞬間瞬間変化して変化して
知識も瞬間瞬間変化していくということを発見する
そうすると結論に達します
すべて無常やと これで生きたいと思っていることが苦であると
実体がないんだと 私がいないんだと
命っていうのはないんだと
昨日だけだと発見するんです
それは仏教用語で無常
苦 無我ということになっているんです
知る必要が消えたら 智慧が現れたら
それが解脱であり 一切智者になることです
この人は一切智者なんです
無常を発見した人が この人は知らないものはないんです
だからバカな人 何妄想するかはわかりませんだけど
全部知ってるんです はい
一切智者のこと この敬語は釈尊に使っているので
敬意を持って弟子たちに使わないのは伝統です
だいたい我々は一切智者と言ったらお釈迦様のことなんですね
一切智者とは釈迦牟尼ブッダです
しかし 智慧を完成した阿羅漢も一切智者なんです
これ英語で言えばテクニカルに
論理的に悟ったら一切智者なんです
もう知ること 知る必要なくなっちゃったんだから
でも我々お釈迦様を尊敬して
我々の師匠だから 自分も一切智者になりましたと絶対言いません
それだけの差なんです
一切智者は自己観察して成功する
誰にでも達することができます
一切できる状況です だから仏教の一切智者っていうのは
ある神だけではなくて
修行する誰でも一切智者になります
そういうオープンな世界なんです
文法は間違ってますけど
あの この一切智 過去なら一切智になって一切智者
まあそれはどうでもいいんです
一切智とはなんですね
自己観察成功する誰にでも達することができる状況です
じゃあ文章ちょっとおかしいんです
あ 終わった 知らないうちに終わりました
まあ結論出ちまったからね
はい 皆さん質問とかあったら出してください
はい では 質問あった方いらっしゃいました
挙手いただきました じゃあまず川本さん
どうぞ  慈悲の瞑想のフルバージョンで心を大地のようにというところはなんとなくわかるんですが
心を空気のようにというところはよくわからない
うん だから空気は何者かとね
イメージすれば大地より大きいでしょ
それだけなんです だから我々はこの悟る前に知識使わなくちゃあかんだから
成長するために はい じゃあそのポイントを説明します
だから知識はゴチですね
どうやってゴチを直すのかというと
最初は知識使うんです
ほか方法ないんです だから川に溺れかけている人が身を守りたければ
何を使う？川を使う 水を使うんです
水を その人殺そうとしてるんです
この人は泳ぐんです 泳ぐときは水が助けになっているんです
泳いで陸に上がって安心ということで
だからこの慈悲の瞑想の場合で
我々は知識を使うんです
その場合はちょっと違う
自分が生きるために 自分の欲望のために使ってはないんです
例えば私の心が大地のようにと言ったら
まあなんか自我がなくなるんですね
大きい人間になるんです
私 私 私というちっちゃな子が大きくなっちゃうんです
空気のように思っちゃうと
もっとすごい広くなっちゃうんです
そういう風に自我の意識を消していくんです
知識を使って はい  よろしいでしょうか
はい では 今ちょっと前に出ましょう
えーと ががが 無我じゃなくて我っていう言葉があると思うんですけども
パーリであったっていうんですか
その意味は何ですか？っていう質問と
あと一つは あの無我になった状態だと
個っていうのが消えるっていう
個 個 個の意識が消えるっていう風にさっき講演だったんですけども
そうするとそのアイデンティティとか自己同一性みたいなんがなくなってしまって
それでなんか昨日の自分と今日の自分の区別がなくなってしまって
混乱状態に陥ってしまう
で あの自己の 自我が崩壊
崩壊というか もうなくなって
それで混乱状態に陥るんじゃないかという疑問がありました
推測では その 生命 いわゆる生命というのは五蘊
色受想行識で構成されているものの流れであるというふうに言ってますので
三位の層がずっと 消えずにずっとあるので
それで自分というものの認識を保ち続けている
キーはキーになっているんじゃないのかくらいしかちょっとわからないんですけども
その側方について教えていただけませんでしょうか
あんた 簡単に答えられる質問が答えられないようにハチャメチャにしちゃったんですね
いろいろ自分の愚痴を入れて解説して
単純に質問だけしてください
それですごい明確に答えられます
補足説明は私には要りません
だから覚えられて覚えたところから答えていきます
あの 自我がなくなったら混乱状態に陥りませんよ
個が消えたら そこは無限の永遠の安穏なんです
だから私が安穏になるわけじゃないんです
だから言語で使う場合は
個が消えたら そちらにあるのは永遠の無限の安穏でありと
微妙です 私が永遠無限無限の安穏になりましたではないんです
それだったらダメです
なってないんです 私が消えるんです
私が消えて混乱に陥ります
なぜならば 初めからもうそれは錯覚なんです
幻覚なんです しかし 無明の生命が存在欲があって
存在欲が知識欲になって知る知ることにする
だから知るためには私というなんとか概念を作らなくちゃいけない
いくらでも概念作れますよ
実在する必要ないんです
数学でXとかYとかテータとかベータとかいろいろシンボル使ってるでしょ
本当はそれは実在しないでしょ
ただ処理するためにもうベータ
テータ ガンマ ランダとかね
ABCDX Yとかね 使ってます
だから A プラス B イコール X にする場合には A
も概念で存在しない プラスというあれも存在しない
ただ 一つアイデアを作るためにそれを使っているだけ
そういう感じで 我々は眼耳鼻舌身意から入る情報を
私という言葉でまとめているんです
ただの言葉であってね
だからそこはシステムわかったらすごい安穏になるんですね
決して混乱しません それから我無我に対する我がということ
それはその通り 言語だからね
言語 単語を作ったら 反対の単語が現れます
インドでは というか すべての人類は自我があるという前提で生きているんです
すべての生命が 自我があるという前提で輪廻転生しているのです
それでお釈迦様がそれは錯覚だよと
ちょっと調べなさいと言っているだけ
それは無我ということなんですね
それは言葉に対して無我と言っているだけなんです
だから実体がないという意味なんですね
私 だから説明してたでしょう
命がないんだけど 認識機能があるんですけど
でも認識機能があると言えない
なぜならば 瞬間瞬間変わるんだから
瞬間瞬間認識が変わるんですね
だから変わるんだけど
川のように流れるだけ
だから川がないんです
実際あるのは水が流れる
だから一回しか流れませんね
もう二度とないんです
認識 そうやって川のように流れるんです
二度と同じ認識は起きません
皆様にこの花 初めて見たでしょ？それから見えてるでしょ
見るたびに同じ認識じゃないんです
違う認識なんです だからそこで変わらない自我があるわけないでしょ
それ発見したら真理の発見なんです
自我が消えたら 私が消えたら
もうすべて悩みがないでしょ
それは頭で考えちゃうと
存在欲で考えているんだから
相当混乱するんです だから我々は実験させるんです
だから実験しない人にとっては相当理解できない
だから初めも言ったでしょ
我々の脳みそが 心が真理がわからないように組み立てなんです
存在欲でできた組み立てだから
別なプログラムは起動しません Mac
コンピューターに Windows プログラムを入れたことと同じです
動かないんです そこでお釈迦様が OS 変えることを推薦している OS
変えたら まあプログラムは動くんです
だから質問には意味があるんです
混乱するんじゃないか
その通りです 知識で見ると混乱するんです
だから自我がなくなったら
そこに 無限の安穏があると
それだけです だから私は無限の安穏になりましたとは言いません
だから阿羅漢たちは俺が悟っているんだよと言いません
だって俺がいないんだから
言うのは まあ悩みなく
苦しみなく 安穏でいるんだよと
聞いたらそういうふうに言うんですね
言っても自我がないんです
ないことは知っているんです
錯覚は消えているんです
はい そんな程度の説明で十分ですかね
理解できなかった方はさらに質問してください
はい じゃあマイクロフォンを次の方に渡してください
同じ質問だと思うんですけれども
先生 さっきここにいる自分が自分
そして外に一歩出た自分はまた違う自分
駅に入ったらまた別の自分
電車で入ったらまた別の自分だってはっきりおっしゃってるんですけれども
頭ではそれこそさっきおっしゃったようにわかるんですけども
やはり同じ自分だと思っちゃうんですね
そして私がいるんだ 実存だっていう風にいつも絶対でも思ってしまう
どうして先生はその違う自分って言えるのか
それは流れだから違うんだろうとは思ってても
それを発見 自分ではできていない
それは発見できてないではなくて
あなたはこれ実行してないんですね
それだけ実行してみると
なんだ楽チンやとわかるんですよ
実行してないっていうより
思えないっていうか  いえいえ
思えないならば ちょっともっと問題は大きいんだけど
え？ 自我意識が強すぎるんだっていうふうには思ってはいたり
足を上げるにしても また同じように上げたんだ
下ろしたんだ また同じように上げたんだ
下ろしたんだと思っている
けれども 本を読むと その一瞬一瞬で現象は生滅して生じている
それさえわかれば無もわかるのかなと思うんですけれども
うん まあそういう あの
素直に疑問を持つのはいいんです
まあ実験中だからね だから仏教で本でこう言ってるんだけど
私には同じ自分がいるように感じるんだとかね
ではもっと調べましょうと
というふうにやった方がいいんですよ
だから この実行していく
使ってみてください このホールにいる自分は違う
外へ出たら別な自分 本当？とちょっとチェックしてください
例えばホールにいると
友達で喋る時の喋り方と
電車に乗って同じ友達で喋る時はテーマが変わるでしょう
それ別の人になってるんですね
そうすると楽ですよ 何か問題が起きて
誰かとすごく喧嘩しましたと
その時は怒っている自分
でもこの人は出ていたら
自分がその部屋から自分の家に戻ったら別自分でしょ
そうすればあの怒りも部屋が部屋を出ると消えているんです
皆さんはそうないでしょ？部屋で二人で喧嘩して怒ったまんまで出ていくんです
出てて自分の部屋に入ってさらに怒っているんです
どこまで怒っているのかと
だからそれで苦しいでしょ
ですから この部屋で二人ですごく喧嘩しちゃって
で はい 終わった もうそれで喧嘩したくないと出て行ったら
別な自分なんですね 瞬間に別な自分になりきってみてください
じゃあ本を読むぞ テレビを見るぞと
またあの過去を背負ってはいけない
これにはちょっと訓練が必要なんですね
そういうふうに実行してみると
どんどんわかるし 悟りにも導くし
悟る前にもすごく楽しく
問題なく生きられる だから悟ってない人は怒って喧嘩する
構いません それはその瞬間にだけして
場が変わったら私は別人だからね
そこでその人はあんたさっき私と喧嘩を売った
いえ 私ではないんだよと
あれはその家 部屋にいた人よ
今私はこちらで本を読んでいるんだと
だからあなたと喧嘩する暇がないんだと
そういうふうに言ってみてください
その人の怒りも消えるし
自分が楽しくなるんです
例えば結婚する時はね
キリスト教でみんな結婚するんだからね
何て言いますか 死ぬまで一緒にとかね
違うでしょ？結婚する人は別で
次の次の日でまた別な人間になってるんですよ
死ぬ時はじいさんばあちゃん死ぬんであって
結婚するした二人は死にません
そういうことで あれは別な自分
これは別な自分という風にした方がすごい精神的に安らぎなんです
すごく微笑んで生きられます
私はそれは大体子供たちには実行しますよ
なぜかというと 子供たちは育てなくちゃいけないんだから
何かやったら それには厳しく言うんですね
厳しく言ったと言って
終わったら それは終わったで
次 次でもそのままで また別なテーマ出して
すごい愛想可愛いという気持ちで
そうですね これでこうこうやりましょうかねとかね
今まで喋ったこととは関係ないんです
だから子供たちにはこれ理解できないんですよ
理解できないんだけど
ああいうあのやった悪いことには言われたんだけど
今それ終わって別なことだと理解しているんだ
だから子供すごい元気になるんです
元気になるだけじゃなくて
言った悪いことは二度とやらない
やらないだけではなくて
やれなくなっているんです
だからこの自分というのは瞬間瞬間変わるのだという前提で何でもうまくいくんです
だからちょっと実行してみてください
面白いですよ  借金の場合はちょっと困りますけどね
借金したのは 3ヶ月か前の人でしょ
今別な自分になって  それは払う羽目になっちゃいますけどね
払い払う時でも本当はね
別な人間がお金に困っていた人間が借金したんだけどね
今私は別やと 今お金があるんだからね
あなたに払いますよと言ってもいいんですよ
別に だから このやったことの結果が
この流れが受けなくちゃいけないんだからね
それはしょうがないんです
これは無常だから流れるんだから
まあちょっと流れに手を加えたら流れが変わるんです
それはもうどうしようもないんですね
それは業というんですね
はい そういうところで理解してください
疑問があることはね それでも私がいるという疑問があることはいいんです
疑問があるんだから これはブッダが言っていることと違うでしょうと
さらに研究しますということで
修行をやってみてください
はい 次の質問  すいません
気づきということについて
気づきとか観察するということについて聞きたいんですけども
知る 知るという仕組みを感覚とか感覚が起きたとか
概念が起きたとか そういうことを知るということについて知っていくみたいなことが観察かなと思ってるんですけども
その知ることを知るっていうことも
やっぱりやっぱり知るっていう機能を使っていると考えていいんでしょうか
うーん  何か別なもの  ちょっと聞き取れないところがいろいろありましたけど
気づきというのは やっぱり知るという機能
気づきとは？ですか 最後の言葉が聞き取れない
知るという  知る あ なるほど
わかった わかった わかった
わかった はい  一番軽い程度の知るなんですね
知るは汚れてないんです
だから知ることからやっぱり正しい承知に行かなくちゃいけないんだからね
でもあまり厳しく取らない
ただ観察するだけと 例えば痛く痛くなったら痛みと観察するだけで
それ以上いかない あ これは嫌だ
痛みをなくさなくちゃいけないんだとか持っていかない
はい 痛み で そこでストップするんですね
そうするとこの汚れてない知ることになるんですね
それで何も判断できない
次の行動に衝動も生まれていない
例えば知識で痛み知ったら痛いというんですね
私が入っていて 痛いんだったら何とかしろという衝動も生まれているんですね
観察の場合はそこは起きないんですね
だから歩く瞑想の場合は
これは散歩でもなく 目的があって歩くことでもないんです
ただ歩く瞑想 歩く瞑想だから
左足上げる運ぶ下ろす
それで終わりという そうすると
これって何なのかと 本人にはわからないんですね
いわゆる愚痴が生まれないんですね
そういう風に知る機能なんですけど
汚れてない知る機能なんですね
観察は それでよろしいですか
はい 何かしら別の機能を使っているというわけではなくて
知るということについて知っているから汚れないという感じでしょうか
大体この観察するのは感覚なんですよ
で 情報思考の場合はただ妄想ということで単純に実況するんですよ
妄想やと それで妄想と言ったっても
それある 後で分解できます
瞑想を続けると 妄想も束だから
それは分解して怒りある
欲があるとかできます
それにはちょっと進め続けなくちゃいけないんですね
で 普通は感覚 痛みとかね
膨らみとか縮みとかね
見えるとか聞こえるとかね
この感覚を確認していくんですね
で 感覚を確認すると 感覚が知識に汚れた知識に変わることにはかなり邪魔なんです
例えばご飯食べる時は運ぶ
入れる 噛む 噛む 味わうというと
今までご飯食べたこととものすごく違っているんです
もうすごい邪魔な ああ
美味しいですねとか これが体にいいですよとかね
これは私の好物ですよとかね
ああいう風に この自我でネズソ世界がそこで結構邪魔されているんですね
だから修行は結構難しくなってるのはそういうわけなんですね
あの 脳にはそういう機能がないんですからね
だからやらなくちゃいけない
そういう風にこの観察する
気づく 口に入れたものの気づく
噛むことに気づく 味わうことに気づく
そこでストップ それ以上はいかない
美味しいやあれやこれやとかね
体にいいか悪いかとかね
そこまでいかない 存在欲まで持っていかない
食べる場合は我々修行者やる場合は観察は先にやりますけど
で これでこの肉体を維持しますと
だから食べているんじゃなくて
肉体が壊れていく 壊れていく肉体にはやっぱり物質を入れて維持しなくちゃいけない
それでもバカバカらしい
どうって壊れるんだから
それでやっぱり解脱に達しなくちゃいけないんだと
だからそこまで観察しなくちゃいけないんだからということで
材料を入れてるんですね
修復材料 だから皆様に教えている食べる瞑想とはちょっとちょっと違うんですが
あの まあ一応まあ似てますけど
微妙な違う 出家の場合とね
最近の場合 修行方法はね
いろいろ変えますからね
それから我々は過去観察というものをやります
過去観察 今日はまあいい加減に観察したりしなかったりして
食事を食べた その食事はもうチイスイカー風で
因果法則で流れるもので
何者でもありませんと
これ食べたという人も
あのチイスイカー風の流れで実体もないし
私もいないし 空でありとという過去形に観察するんです
私は現在形の観察よりは
過去形の観察をすごく気に入っているんです
はい 私はいませんと 生命はこちらにいませんと
すべて空であるという観察は
自分個人的に気に入っているんです
だからこの過去 これやっているんです
はい そこはね 観察することは知いで言いたければ知ることなんですが
知ることは中身が違う
汚れていない知ることになります
はい 以上です  ありがとうございました
はい 他の方 じゃあこちらの方から
はい  簡単な質問です 簡単な質問です
罪 悪いことに相当する
どこ？先生のやられている専門の仏教では何かそういう言葉はあるんですか？ 罪ということ
罪  うん あの解脱の世界では善も悪もないんです
無常の流れだけなんですね
だから  字はよくわかるんですけども
漢字ね 中国文学の漢字で
中国では罪っていう単語はもうものすごくよく出てくる単語なんです
で インドと中国の仏教は違うと思うんですけども
インドの方 お釈迦さんはその悪いこと
罪についてどう言ってたのか
それが知りたいってことです
罪っていうのは この罪が善と罪ですね
どれいつでもペアで使うんですよ
善と悪というね だからこの宗教では
この罪って仏教でもありますよ
その場合もペアなプンヤパーク
功徳と罪 善と悪 そういうふうにペアにしているんですよ
いつでも これは必ずペアで使わなくちゃいけないんです
なぜならば 一つがあってもう一つ成り立っているんです
だから独立性はないんです
罪にも 罪の反対なんですか？よくわかりませんだけど
功徳なんですね あの仏教はそこは相対的でというふうにとっているんですね
そんなことで 罪を犯したら当然結果が悪いんだから
だからやめるべきということになるんですね
で これはね いろんな定義できますけどね
例えば人は生きていきたいと思っている
生きていきたいと思っているならば
楽に幸せで簡単で生きられる道を選びなさいよと
勝手に生きることはできませんよと
そこで勝手なことをすると罪なんです
俺が食べたいんだから
お前を殺すんだというと罪なんです
自分のことしか考えてないんだから
俺が損するんだから 嘘をついてやると
で そうすると嘘はやがてバレるんだからね
自分には簡単で安穏で幸せに生きることはできなくなっているんです
自分の都合で人を殺したら
自分の命がもうそれで終わってしまうんですね
だから存在生きていきたければ
安穏で楽しく 平和で幸せで生きるように道を選びなさいと
そこで善悪が成り立つのです
例えば酒を飲んではいけないと言っているでしょ
仏教では でも人間は酒を飲む
で 仏教では酒飲んだら体が壊れる
病気になる 脳みそが壊れる
そうなると平和で生きていられなくなります
頭が悪くなる 依存になる
だったらやめな やめましょうと
よくわかりました ありがとうございました
そういうふうな感じなんですね
では順番に参ります はい
ちょっと先にこちらの
これはすごく日本でしかないことなのかもしれないんですけども
日本の仕事の世界では忖度っていう言葉で示される行動があります
何かというと 仕事の中の上司が何も言わなくても
その下の一緒に働いている下の人たちが気を回していろんなことをして
その上 ピースの仕事全体がうまくいくように取り計らってあげる
そういうことを知るっていうことが大事なんだっていうことが
日本の世界で 日本の仕事の世界でよく言われているところなんですけれども
私は今日のお話を聞いて
まさにそれって存在欲の極みだと思っているのですが
先生のいらっしゃる仏教の観点から
先ほどのような行動 もしくはそういう
そういうことを感知して行動してあげるっていうのは
どういう意味になるのかというのを教えていただけると嬉しいです
あのどうせ噛み合わないところがありますよ
だから仕事だけじゃなくて
ずっと人生 24時間知ることによって成り立ってるんですよ
そこでグループで行動する場合も知ることが必要なんですよ
だから知ることは存在欲だからね
会社に行って仕事をするのは存在欲でしょう
生きていきたいからでしょ
それはまあ そういうことで理解してほしい
だから会社の場合は存在欲というのは仕事をうまくはかどって
能率が上がって利益がたくさんあること
家族の場合は存在欲というのは利益があるかないかではなくて別なんですね
家族の場合 お互い仲良く楽しく
子供たちはしっかり勉強して
夫婦がお互い仲良く間に合って
お金やらいろいろお互いいろいろまあ考えて組み合わせて生活することですね
それで友達の場合はまた別なことになるんですね
だから この知ることはそのその環境によって変わるんです
で 例えば物を売るという仕事になってくると
だから買う人がいて 売る人がいて
そこで別な知る働きが機能しなくちゃいかんですね
買う人がこれは買わなくちゃいけないという知識にならなくちゃいけない
売る人はこれは買う気にさせなくちゃいけないという知識を使わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 生きる上で 24時間も知識は使います
その場でその場で使う知識の何といいますか
質が変わります 知識は無数に無限にありますからね
だから会社で言ってることはそんなものでしょう
だからその場合は 仏教徒としてできるだけ自我を捨てて考えた方が楽なんです
自我を捨てて組織にするんですね
会社も組織で 人間も組織ですね
だから個人にはほんのわずかな仕事があるんですね
で このわずかな仕事をちゃんと貢献すると
組織がうまく起動するんだと
だから上司が何言っても
まあこの組織が問題なく起動するようにと自分の貢献する分を貢献してあげれば
すごい気楽に進むとは思います
まあそれも存在は存在ですよ
だからその知識は愚痴でしょうし
輪廻転生する限りはこれはしょうがないし
だから仏教の承知の世界と俗世間というのは噛み合わない別世界なんですね
全く別世界なんです しかし
仏教の知識は俗世間にはうまく使えるんです
真理ですからね そういうところは区別判断して使ってみてください
いや 先にこちらはい  2つあるんですけれども
1つ目はあちらの質問と関連するんですけれども
あの 何ですか 汚れて汚れている
汚れた思考と汚れていない
汚れていない思考の痛みだとか
そういった認識というのは生起になるんでしょうか
なりますね  うん それは無常苦無常と同じ
そこは智慧が現れたら無常苦無が見えますけど
智慧が現れる以前ですから
例えば見えるだけにしたら汚れてないんです
痛みがあるだけで止まったらすごく汚れてない
承知なんです  はい ありがとうございます
もう一つは 割愛という言葉がですね
割愛 はい 昔からよくわからなくてですね
今日は存在欲を聞いてですね
まあそうだと思ったんですけど
どうして渇きという人愛という字を使って
割愛っていうのは 日本語でいう渇きとか愛を使って存在欲を言うのかというところが全くわからなくて
どうして割愛なんだろう
ちょっと日本語の問題なのかもしれないですけど
それは日本漢文にするときに割愛してるんですけど
パーリ語では一単語なんですね
でもそこは疑問になるように
えっ？なんだこれというふうに思ってほしいんだから
お釈迦様はこの智慧でこの単語を選んでいるんです
パーリ語でタンハというと
えっ なんだこれはわからないということになっちゃうんですね
渇愛と言ったって えっ
何これ？と やっぱり知り調べなくちゃいけない羽目になるんです
だから そういうお釈迦様の智慧で人々を解脱に導くために選んでいる用語なんですね
だから 存在欲っていうのは渇愛で
愛とは生きていきたいという気持ちなんですね
これ 渇っていうのはもういつでも乾いた状態で終わりがない
例えば今日生きていきたいんだからご飯食べる
終わらないんですね また食べなくちゃいけない
生きていきたいんだから呼吸する
生きていきたいんだから吸う
でも吐かなくちゃいけない
吐いたら終わらない また吸わなくちゃいけない
これ終わらないよと いくらやっても渇きは消えませんと
で 塩水飲んでるような感じやというふうに理解すると
なんとか存在欲っていうのは面倒くさいなというふうにわかってくれると
はい どうもありがとうございました
そういうふうなことです
はい では  自分が感情的になった時に
感情的になっている自分に対して気づきを入れたくて
えー今 妄想が湧いて 妄想
妄想 怒り 怒り 恐れ 恐れっていう風に頭の中で考えて
いるんですが これは 良いことなのでしょうか
当たり前でしょう そうやって確認することが
これは修行ですよ これやっていると
あなたはどんどんどんどん真理を発見するんです
1 日で全て実るわけじゃないんだからね
種を植えただけでね 実りませんだからね
もうずっと実るまで続くだけなんです
ここでちょっと加えて言いたいんだけど
例えば感情になったら怒りとかね
もうもう怯えとかなんとか感情を確認するでしょ
その時も血があるんですね
ある知識が あの知識が相当汚れてるんだよと理解してほしい
そこで知識は次の行動を決めるでしょ
知識間違ってるんだから
その行動をやめてください
例えば怒りの感情が出る
出たら怒りからで自分に言う
しかし 怒っていることが知識にもなる
知識は次の行動を指令する
これやらない なぜならばとんでもないことになるんだ
これは間違った判断だよと
冷静になった時は行動しますと
例えば怒ったら人を怒鳴るんじゃなくて
怒ったことは正しいとしましょう
相手が本当に悪いことをしましたと
いけないことをしましたと
自分を侮辱しましたと
それはいけないこと その場で怒ったでしょ
その場では何もしません
それで怒りが消えたところで
過去のことなんですけど
何か言ってもいいんですね
あんたね 昨日こういうふうな言葉を言ったんだけど
あれはすごく侮辱で失礼なことやと
私はその時はものすごく怒りましたからね
二度とそういうことをやるなよと
今怒ってない 楽しく良い心で言ってるんですね
そういうふうにこの感情に気づく
感情から生まれる知識はいつでもあまりも間違っている
だから行動に行かないように気をつけることは戒めになるんです
それで良いことをしたんだから
あなたにちょびっと知恵が現れてくる
ちょびっと良い生き方見えてくる
その訓練によって 正しい生き方はどんどんどんどん経験的にわかっていくんです
そういうふうにやってみてください
ありがとうございます
二つ質問がございます
長老自身が一切知者になったのはいつですか？また
どのようにどのようにしてそうなったのか
ちょっと聞き取れない
何を聞いてるんですか？ 長老が一切知者になったのはいつですか？どのようにですか
これ分かりませんよ 自我の問題だからね
本当に素直に正直に分かりません
うん 次の質問 だから具体的に別なもうこんなことだったら長老ならどうするのかというふうに質問すると
私の生き方は説明できますけど
一切知者になったのかどうかが聞いちゃうと
え？ということになるんです
はい 次の質問 2つあるでしょ
死んだ後は別の何かになると思うと私は思っていますが
長老自身のそう 長老自身やお釈迦様はどのようにお考えになっているんですか？ それもちょっと
死んだ後は何かに生まれ変わる
死んだ後は別の何かになると思ってるんですか？ あのね
この生きてる死んでるとか
全て相対的な単語で 仏教ではこれ同じ同義語なんで
生きると死ぬとは 今私は生きているとも言えるし
今私は死んでいるとも言えます
これ理解できればね 死んでから何かなるということは成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
生きることが死ぬことでもある
だからだからみんなこの言語が間違ってますよ
生きると言ったら連続してるでしょ？私は生きているんだということは
ずっと生きてる 生きて生きてきて
生きていることでしょう
死んでいると言ったら一回限りやと思ってる
そこは間違いなんです
生きる死ぬ同じ意味なんですね
生き続けている 死続けているなんです
だから死んでからどうなるかっていうことがあんまり成り立たない
今も死んでるんですよ
死んで死んで 死んで死んでいってるんですね
その時 次のことになるんです
例えば講演会に私は来た
私が今いないよ １時半の私がもうとっくに死んでるんです
今４時半の自分なんですね
その流れで変わったんです
全然当たり前なんですね
だからこの肉体 肉体が停止することだけみんな死だと思ってるんですけど
それは誤解なんですね
肉体は停止したら それは停止して次の当たり前のことになるんです
そんな程度にしてください
ありがとうございます
あの 毎日の仕事をしている中などで
自分はダメだなとか 他の人と比較してダメだなと思ったりするのがエゴの自我のせいなんだろうと思うんですけども
で 歩く瞑想だとか 自分の動きがあるだけだとかですね
感覚があるとか こう自分っていうのはないんだというふうに思うことが
無責任な態度を物事に取ることとどう違うんだろうかと
無責任にならないよ すごいしっかり生きられます
だから今私はダメだっていうことは消えちゃいます
あんた自分がなかったら適当に適切に対応するんです
例えば人に叱られてても
自分がいないんだったら
その言葉に反応できませんよ
自分がいると間違って反応するんです
だから自分がいないということは
推測ででもね 使ってみるとすごくうまく流れるんです
ふりをしてみるってこと
そのいないふりをしてみるってことなんでしょうか
これふりじゃないんですね
結局は本当のことだからね
だから今わかってないんだから
なんとなく真似というかね
ふりはまあね あまりよくないんですね
我々わかってないんだけど
本当は自分がいないんだというふうにした方がいいんですね
自分がいないということは真理であると
経験悟ってないから あなたにとってはそれは一つの概念ですよ
でも概念こそも正しいんだから
ふりをする必要はないんですね
仏教ではちょっと真似をしてみるんですね
真似する場合は どうしても良いことの真似するでしょ
例えば歌ってる時でも
すごい立派な歌手の歌を真似するんですね
あの音痴の真似しないでしょ？しないね
ですから真似なんです
ふりじゃないんです だからふりに言うと
なんかごまかしで 真似の場合はごまかしてないんです
真似ですからね ただ真似してうまくいったかないかだけなんですね
それからもう一つ 私がダメだと思うことは当然自我なんですけど
もう一つあります 私はダメで何が悪い？だって知ってることより知らないの方が多いでしょ
友達に至っても その友達のことはの知ってることほんのわずかでしょ
友達の知らない世界膨大でしょ
だからダメでいいんです
だから私はダメで能力がなくて何が悪いのかって対応してみててください
ありがとうございます
えーとですね 中道と向き
阿弥陀方は中道と向き
阿弥陀方ってありますか？ 中道
中道  あ 中道  中道と向きが向き
阿弥陀方がどういうふうに関係しているのか
ああ 阿弥陀方っていうのは間違った概念で間違った思想をしているんだから
答えが成り立たない 例えば
ウサギの角が長いものですか
短いものですかと聞いちゃうと
どう答えればいいんですかね
2つ選んでくださいと
長いか短いかと そこで私はちょっともう余計に長いとするために何センチですかと
短にするために何センチだと相手に聞く
相手はまあ 5センチだったら短い方で
5 センチ以下は 5 センチ以上は長い方にしましょうと言ったって答えられる？答えられない
それは阿弥陀方なんだ
中道っていうのはそういう
そこはもう話にならない
阿比夜カタの世界はね
ただ 我々の偏見は偏見であることを知っていることだけなんですね
だから偏見は我々の知識だからね
それはウサギの砂じゃないよ
例えば日本の米は柔らかくておいしいと皆様思っているでしょうに
あれってウサギの砂じゃないんです
インドでは一番高級米はバスマティという名前の米なんですよ
香りがあるんですけど
日本人があまり好きじゃないんです
だから日本人がやっぱりインドの高級米かもしれませんだけど
ちょっと日本の米食べますよというのは
もうウサギの砂じゃないんでしょ
それは我々の経験的な知識なんですね
知識は偏見であると理解するところで中道なんです
真島なんです うん よろしいですか？それ
その阿比夜カタっていうのが
なんかこう アビダンマでは善
善行 善と悪があって  あ
あなた別のアビヤカタって聞いてる
え？ 善でも悪でもない
カルマを作らない  行為のみ
そうそう  それはそれで
それとその中道っていうのはなんか似てるようで
よくわかんないですね
関係  それは関係あるんですね
例えば心情が悟った人の場合はすべてアッビヤカタになるんです
行為のみになるんですね
それは中道に達しているんだからなんです
その場合は似て同じなんです
アッビヤカタが このアビダルマのアッビヤカタは中道なんです
中道というか 中正中小なんです
同じものです  ということは
中道が原因で阿比夜カタが結果っていうことじゃない
心相一緒に働くんだだからね
修行するときでも いろんな心相が一緒に働くでしょ
どちらかっていうとはっきりはしない
知恵と知恵という心情にするんですね
だから他の善心情も一緒にないと修行できません
その中で決定権を持っているのは知恵なんですね
パンニャーなんですね
パンニャーが正しくなってくると
全ての心情がアッビヤカタになってしまうんです
だから中道というか 中というのは知恵のことなんです
一緒に働くんです うん
わかりました  それではいろいろ質問をいただいておりますけど
もう会場の時間が迫ってきておりますので
これで終了したいと思います
これ出してください  ちょっと照明を落としていただけますか？はい
では最後に皆様これ唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェニンドゥッカ
バヤッパッタチェニンバヤ
ソウカッパッタチェニッソウカ
ホントゥサンビピパニノ
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
カンティ  パラマンタポティティンカニッバーナンのパラマンワダンティブッダ
ブッダ